THE ONE WE HAVE EXCLUSIVE NEW
DETAILS TONIGHT ABOUT FORMER FBI
AGENT PETER STRZOK'S LAWSUIT
OVER HIS FIRING.
HE INFAMOUSLY SENT A NUMBER OF
ANTI-TRUMP TEXT TO HIS GIRL
FRIEND AND LOVER LISA PAGE
DURING THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION
AND WAS ULTIMATELY LET GO.
LAST WEEK, HE FILED A LAWSUIT
CLAIMING HE WAS FIRED UP "AS A
RESULT OF UNRELENTING PRESSURE
FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS
POLITICAL ALLIES IN CONGRESS AND
THE MEDIA WHICH INCLUDED
"CONSTANT TWEETS AND OTHER
DISPARAGING STATEMENTS BY THE
PRESIDENT, AS WELL AS DIRECT
APPEALS FROM THE PRESIDENT AND
THEN ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFFERSON
SESSIONS AND FBI DIRECTOR
CHRISTOPHER WRAY.
JOINING ME NOW IS TREY GOWDY.
AND FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
I HAD THE PLEASURE AND HONOR OF
SERVING WITH MR. GAUDI
THROUGHOUT MY TIME IN CONGRESS
AND I LIKE THE SPECTACLE THAT
YOU HAVE GOING ON NOW.
WE ARE EXPECTING SOMETHING
DRAMATIC WITH YOUR HAIR OR YOUR
SUIT BUT I LOVE THE GLASSES AND
I'M GLAD THAT YOU COULD JOIN US
HERE TONIGHT.
>> MICK MULVANEY TOLD ME THAT
GLASSES MAKE YOU LOOK SMARTER
BUT I DON'T THINK THIS WORKS FOR
EITHER ONE OF US.
>> Jason: THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR JOINING US HERE.
YOU ARE ONE OF THE FEW PEOPLE,
YOU AND JOHN RADCLIFFE WHO HAVE
READ THE UNREDACTED VERSION OF
THE SO-CALLED THREE OH TWO, YOU
HAVE PETER STRZOK WHO WAS FIRED
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT WAS
TWEETING ABOUT HIM BUT WHAT'S A
REALITY ABOUT HOW AND WHY HE WAS
FIRED?
>> MEMBER HE SAID HE WAS FIRED
BECAUSE HE WAS EXERCISING HIS
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO FREE
SPEECH BUT HE ALSO OFFERED TO
ACCEPT A 60 DAY DEMOTION.
HE OFFERED TO TAKE A CUT IN PAY
AND HE EXPRESSED A PROFOUND
REMORSE.
SO YOU DON'T EXPRESS PROFOUND
REMORSE FOR EXIT SIZING
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED RIGHT
AND YOU DON'T AGREE TO A 60 DAY
SUSPENSION, A CUT IN PAY AND A
DEMOTION IF YOU HAVEN'T DONE
ANYTHING WRONG.
SO THAT'S WHAT HE DID.
WHO FIRED HIM?
IT WASN'T ANY OF THE PEOPLE HE
SUED IRONICALLY ENOUGH, IT WAS
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE FBI.
IT WAS DAVID BOWDITCH.
HE'S A CAREER FBI GUY, NOT A
POLITICAL APPOINTEE.
LET ME GIVE YOU A FLAVOR OF HIS
BACKGROUND.
HE WAS A LOCAL COP THAT BECAME A
BUREAU AGENT, HE WAS A S.W.A.T.
TEAM GUY AND THIS IS WHAT HE DID
WHEN HE WAS IN THE PIRO.
HE INVESTIGATED STREET GANGS IN
LOS ANGELES LIKE THE BLOODS AND
THE CRIPS.
HE INVESTIGATED EXIT CAN DRUG
CARTELS AND A GROUP CALLED
HELLS ANGELS.
NOT "CHARLIE'S ANGELS,"
I DON'T THINK A GUY WHO HAS DONE
THAT FOR HIS ENTIRE CAREER IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS GOING TO BE
INTIMIDATED BY A TWEET OR TWO
FROM ANYBODY AND THAT'S WHO MADE
THE DECISION TO FIRE PETER
STRZOK.
>> Jason: THESE ARE ACTUALLY
FOUND ON HIS GOVERNMENT ISSUED
PHONES AND, AS I RECALL IT WAS
MICHAEL HOROWITZ WHO IS THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL WHO HAD TO
ENGAGE THE PENTAGON TO DEVELOP
THE ALGORITHM BECAUSE THE FBI
SAID THEY COULDN'T FIND THESE
TEXTS.
BUT SURE ENOUGH THEY WENT TO THE
PENTAGON, DEVELOP THE ALGORITHM
AND THEY DID MAGICALLY GET THE
TEXT.
>> I THINK HOROWITZ FOUND SOME
OF THEM AND THEN THERE WAS A GAP
WHERE IT WAS MISSING.
HE'S DONE A FANTASTIC JOB AND I
SEE WITH THE SUICIDE OF JEFFREY
EPSTEIN OR THE APPARENT SUICIDE,
AND HE HAS MORE WORK ON HIS
HANDS.
HE WAS A STRAIGHT SHOOTER AND HE
DID FIND HIM, HE DOES DESERVE
CREDIT FOR THAT.
BUT IF IT WEREN'T FOR HOROWITZ,
WE WOULD NEVER KNOW THE PERSON
LEADING THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION
HAD AN HISTORIC LEVEL OF ANIMUS
TOWARD THE PEOPLE HE CLAIMS TO
BE DISPASSIONATELY INVESTIGATIN
INVESTIGATING.
>> Jason: I WANT TO MOVE ON TO
BRUCE OHR.
HE WAS THE ASSOCIATE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ORGANIZED CRIME AND DRUG
ENFORCEMENT TASK FORCE.
THAT'S HIS TITLE.
BUT WHY WOULD HE BE INVOLVED AND
ENGAGED IN ANY PROXIMITY TO
TRUMP, RUSSIA AND THE PROBE
THAT -- IT MAKES NO SENSE.
>> I DON'T KNOW, LET ME THINK.
IT COULDN'T BE BECAUSE HIS WIFE
WAS WORKING FOR FUSION GPS?
I READ THOSE THREE OH TWO'S
SEVERAL YEARS AGO.
I'M JUST AS STUNNED.
I USED TO WORK FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND I HOLD
IT IN VERY HIGH REGARD.
BUT YOU HAVE AN FBI SOURCE WHO
WAS DEFROCKED.
HE WAS LET GO BECAUSE HE
COULDN'T FOLLOW THE RULES AND,
BY THE WAY HE WAS DESPERATE TO
KEEP DONALD TRUMP FROM BECOMING
THE PRESIDENT.
THEY GOT RID OF HIM AND THEY
CANNED HIM, LEGITIMATELY SO.
THEN HE FINDS A WILLING CONDUIT
OF INFORMATION.
THAT'S CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
HE CAN'T TALK TO THE BARREL
ANYMORE SO HE TALKS TO A SENIOR
LEVEL DOJ OFFICIAL, AND IT'S
UNHEARD OF.
FIRST OF ALL, IMAGINE A LOCAL
COP OR LOCAL INFORMANT OR SOURCE
WHO WAS LET GO BECAUSE THEY ARE
BIASED AND THEY CAN'T FOLLOW THE
RULES?
YOU WOULDN'T WANT THEM ON ANY
KIND OF CASE AND MUCH LESS AN
INVESTIGATION LIKE THIS.
BUT BRUCE OHR CARRIED THIS
INFORMATION TO DOJ AND PUT
HIMSELF IN THE CHAIN OF CUSTODY
WHICH IS UNHEARD OF FOR A
PROSECUTOR.
I'M STUNNED WHEN I READ THE
ARTICLES BUT I KNEW ABOUT IT A
YEAR AGO SO I GUESS MY LEVEL OF
STUNNED HAS DISSIPATED.
>> Jason: AND NELLIE OHR IS
1 OF 20 EMPLOYEES AT FUSION GPS.
AND YOU COULD NO LONGER DO
BUSINESS WITH MR. STEELE BUT
THIS TIMELINE IS SUCH THAT THEY
CONTINUE TO DO BUSINESS
TOGETHER.
>> RIGHT, BUT WHY?
THEY HAVE A SOURCE THAT THEY
CAN'T KEEP AS A SOURCE.
THE PUNISHMENT IS, YOU ARE NO
LONGER A SOURCE.
THE PUNISHMENT IS NOT YOU GET
YOUR INFORMATION TO THE DOJ
ANOTHER WAY, IT DOESN'T WORK
THAT WAY.
>> JERRY NADLER HAS CAUSED A LOT
OF CONFUSION ON A LOT OF FRONTS.
BUT THE IDEA IS, IS THIS
IMPEACHMENT OR IS IT NOT
IMPEACHMENT?
IS IT FORMAL IMPEACHMENT OR
INFORMAL IMPEACHMENT, WHICH IS
IT?
>> I WOULD HAVE ME DO YOU WEAR A
TUXEDO AND SET UP SHIRT.
WHAT IS INFORMAL IMPEACHMENT?
YOU HAVE SOME REALLY CHARISMATIC
POLITICIANS, AND HE WILL BE IN
TROUBLE IN THE NEXT ELECTION
CYCLE SO HE'S TRYING TO --
NOBODY IS FALLING FOR THIS
FORMAL VERSUS AND FORMAL
IMPEACHMENT.
YOU WILL WIN IN THE HOUSE AND
LOSE IN FRONT OF THE JURY, GO
AHEAD AND DO IT.
BUT THERE IS NO SUCH THING AS
INFORMAL IMPEACHMENT.